[Music]
courtroom drama delivers some of tv's
highest ratings
[Music]
so this dark reality a hollywood
scriptwriter's dream
sordid
star studded
saddening
at the heart of this brutal seven week
court battle contradicting claims over
domestic abuse
it just hit me over and over and over
again and i got really still
and it
felt in my body like quiet
and
i thought this is how i die
never
did i myself
reach the point of um
uh
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
[Music]
you'd be forgiven for a sense of deja vu
as in the summer of 2020 disturbing
evidence of johnny depp and aberhard's
violent and messy marriage was poured
over at the high court as johnny depp
took on the sun and lost the judge
ultimately deciding that the newspaper
was justified in describing him as a
wife beater
[Applause]
so this case the sequel and the evidence
again has been shocking but its impact
felt way beyond this courtroom the
unique nature of johnny depp's fan base
securing huge influence
def's fan base has acted as his external
pr arm uh the justice for johnny depp
hashtag has been really popular and on
twitter and it's been a way of people
spending information and creating a bit
of sympathy for johnny depp so i think
they've been really active and i think
he owes them a check or two
depp's star power dwarfs amber herds an
imbalance that has led to his ex-wife
being vilified online
depp's lawyers are using tremendous
amount of resource to get a message
across that she's a broken woman she's
unstable she's a psychopath she's
untrustworthy
none of this is directed towards johnny
depp
the campaign against me that's echoed
every single day
on social media i receive
hundreds
of death threats
regularly if not daily
thousands since this trial has started
people mocking
mocking
my testimony about being assaulted
perhaps the most profound performances
of their lives that could well spell the
end of their careers
i have a feeling we will see each other
again a verdict with little victory when
the battle has been so brutal
katy spencer sky news